speaking of Elizabeth Warren yesterday I told
you that Elizabeth Warren had taken a one
point lead in the New Hampshire primary over
Biden and a two point lead in New Hampshire
over Bernie.
Now since then, we have had another New Hampshire
poll which shows Bernie ahead and we also
have a new national economist poll, which
has Elizabeth Warren tied with Joe Biden Nationally
26 to 26 this is not a single state.
Okay.
This is national polling other than a single
Monmouth poll in mid August, Joe Biden has
led every poll nationally dating all the way
back to before he even announced he was running
and we now have tonight a Democratic primary
debate where Elizabeth Warren is at least
in one poll, not trying to catch Joe Biden
but co front runner with Joe Biden at 26 26
so let's look at this one pole.
And remember it's just one pole, but this
is still very, very notable.
Also notable is that in this poll, Bernie
Sanders is all the way down to 16% which I
actually do find difficult to believe.
So it's always important to consider one poll.
No more than that.
It is just one data point.
Unless there has been a significant real shift
away from Bernie towards Warren.
It's difficult to imagine that both Bernie
and Warren are each 10 points ahead of Bernie,
but this is one poll, so now that we've seen
this, what you need to do is nothing different.
What I mean is it's the same situation as
always.
You need to stay engaged, you need to go vote
when your state votes, no matter what the
polls say.
But this is very interesting in terms of the
dynamics for tonight's debate, which for me
has become a lot more interesting in light
of these recent polling changes.
Will the tone and the feel of tonight's debate
be different because Warren is no longer,
at least in this poll, trying to come from
behind Biden and make her case, but rather
a co front runner.
If you are Biden, are you panicking?
Maybe not.
It's unclear how much Joe Biden actually wants
to be president, but presuming that he really
does want to be president of the United States,
if you are Joe Biden, you have to be worried
about Elizabeth Warren's momentum.
I got some emails yesterday in light of this
new poll saying, Hey, David Biden's should
step down.
I find this a little bit silly.
Rarely would anyone who is leading, even if
it's tied for the lead.
Step aside, unless the argument about momentum
is so overwhelming and Biden really doesn't
want to be president of the United States,
I don't see Biden stepping down anytime soon,
but now there is a real fight and the questions
of speaking time in tonight's debate will
be immediate questions.
We tend to see those who are leading get disproportionately
more speaking time and while in one sense
that's completely unfair.
In another sense, it's completely expected.
Once you understand the corporate nature of
these debates on the major networks, will
speaking time be impacted by the fact that
at least in this poll, Elizabeth Warren is
a co front runner with Joe Biden.
We
will have to see.
I hope you will join me for a pre-debate stream
on youtube a half hour before the debate starts
and then live debate commentary over on twitter@twitch.tv
slash [inaudible]
David Pacman if, and this is a big, big, if,
if nobody shuts us down, uh, all of that.
Can I let me know what you think about this
new Paul, t